someone says Rocky's a sports film again
I was wait why does that upset you
because it's not what is it clear it up
right now
what is Rocky is a love story about a
guy who's a broken down fighter that's
all it is but boxing I realize people
are obsessed with two things in life
racing and boxing in every aspect oh you
gotta race to beat the club where you
get your tax return race race race race
you got your final son it's always going
somewhere and I thought okay what's the
other thing that everyone relates to
symbolically fighting as soon as a guy
walks in the room he slides up another
guy oh how would I last against him and
then it gets down to you realize
life is a big battle man there's like
there's no flat spots just you solve one
problem and you got another one one
thing after another fighting so I
thought if I could write a story that
deals with a guy who on the outside
looks like a real tough guy should maybe
have it together and he has nothing to
get and people can relate to that yeah
because he doesn't even think of himself
as tough he's just a loser and he admits
he's a loser